New Jersey health officials they are
racing to contain a deadly virus
outbreak that has killed seven children
and sickened 11 others the adenovirus is
what it's called it's spreading at a
facility that cares for children with
compromised immune systems CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Michelle Miller
is at the facility in Haskell New Jersey
with more on this story Michelle good
morning good morning the State Health
Department is on site to help stop the
spread of this virus because in communal
facilities like this where there are
extremely vulnerable patients this virus
the adenovirus can move fast the virus
spread quickly at the Wanaque center
infecting the most vulnerable the deaths
all happened last month in the part of
the facility that provides long-term
care for medically fragile children
ranging from newborns up to age 22 an
inspection found minor hand-washing
deficiencies at the location the State
Health Department says it's working
closely with the facility on infection
control issues adenoviruses make up
about five to ten percent of fevers and
young children the infection spreads
like a common cold and most patients
recover after a brief illness this
strain of adenovirus has been associated
with communal living this isn't a strain
that is around a lot it will kind of
come and go dr. claudia houyan is a
pediatric infectious disease specialist
she says this outbreak is severe because
the victims are high-risk some patients
at the Wanaque facility are severely
disabled including those on ventilators
someone who's otherwise healthy doing
well this strain probably isn't going to
be a problem
but it's just when you have that layer
of being compromised from something
those are patients that are going to get
into trouble it is unclear what started
this outbreak but State Health
Department officials have told the
Wanaque Center to stop admitting new
patients we haven't been able to reach
anyone inside here but we are told that
the administrator on-site is cooperating
with State Health Department official
at this time Michelle Miller Thank You
Michelle